scottson nevada hey scott welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show thanks Dave I
appreciate you taking my call sure
what's up I'm uh I'm having a problem
with really getting my wife on board
she's excited that I'm excited about
your plan she's she's happy to get the
debt paid off but she wants to get her
credit back too good and I have I've
read your books complete guide to money
in the total money money makeover but
she doesn't have the attention span that
to read much I I've got a plan and I've
tried to get her involved but she
doesn't understand and I have tried to
explain how old is she um she is 42 how
long have you been married 25 years good
for you okay
um there are things in this world that
your wife cares deeply about and thus
far this has not been one of them is
that right well it's my besty doesn't
care she doesn't care enough to do
something about it
mm-hmm and so what that means is is that
you have a bigger vision for your money
and what could happen then she does
she's okay kind of just coasting along
and so the answer to your equation is
when she or anyone for that matter gets
a bigger why why I'm doing this why
would I bother to care about this why
would I put my energy into it why would
I give this my attention
why would I sacrifice to win then the
only reason you would do any of those
things is if you have a why a big reason
and so you need to pan back from telling
her all these things you're going to do
and what what what what what we're gonna
do what we're gonna do here's what we're
gonna do okay that's great I'm glad
you're excited about you go ahead know
what what you've just been telling her
all the details and all the tactical
things and you need to pan
and get above this with her and just sit
down and have it what Chris Hogan calls
a dream meeting and say okay what if we
had a couple of million dollars and no
debt we could start to do almost
anything we wanted to do what would that
mean to us as a couple and then shut up
and let her tell you what she would want
to do if you were in that situation and
that's starting to be what her dream is
it's starting to be what her why is she
may tell you she's always wanted to
travel to Italy and you didn't even know
that she may tell you she's always
wanted to own a farm and you didn't even
know that with horses on it and you
didn't even know that or cows on it and
you didn't even know that I don't know
but let's find out if you could dream
again and then take that one step
further and again as Chris Hogan says
put those dreams keep discussing those
dreams until they're there fleshed out
and they're high-def dreams HD High
Definition where they have a lot of
detail I'd like to go on a cruise
someday okay
where oh and and where would you like to
see on the cruise how long would you
like to be on the cruise would you like
to do a luxury cruise would you like to
do a land package but for the cruise for
two weeks or after that you know would
you want to go in the summer of the
winter and really start to nail that
down and go okay I don't care what the
thing is I'm making up things here
trying to come up with but what would
you know I've always wanted to give to
this ministry I've always wanted to
spend three months on the mission field
I've always wanted to help starving
children in Haiti and go work in an
orphanage I don't know what the thing is
right that that that that gives her some
excitement but that you need to learn
that because then that is the reason to
do all this crap we don't get out of
debt just to get out that we get our
debts so that we can build wealth so
that we can be outrageously generous so
that we can have a higher quality of
life and you got to get
behind the so that's and what's happened
in your situation Scott is you
personally have already gone there you
went well god if I could get this mess
cleaned up we could do this and we could
do this and we could do this and and so
then you turn around and instantaneously
went to work on cleaning the mess up and
she's like been Scott's kind of going
crazy over here well that's cool good
for Scott you know instead of going what
in a flip that we don't have a we don't
have a joined goal here we don't have a
our goal is not set together instead
she's just watching all this positive
activity out of you which is good and
she's she's affirming that but she's
kind of a disinterested party watching
you like a zoo animal and so instead of
being the the other tiger that's in the
hunt and so and that's what it comes
down to what are you hungry for and when
Sharon Ramsey gets on something like
that she'll work me to death and I don't
need to work anymore
don't give them woman a go oh man don't
give her a dream cuz she'll make me go
get it
and that's that's good because that
means we're working together and that
means we have a shared vision for our
life we have shared goals we have shared
fears we have shared wise we have shared
motivation and that's what draws couples
together more and more and more when
they're doing this stuff but the things
Sharon used to do when we were first
married the classic southern belle line
is oh it's passive-aggressive right
whatever you want to do honey whatever
you want to do honey it's kind of like
bless your heart it can mean a whole lot
of different stuff whatever you want to
do honey generally means I kind of think
you're crazy and when you mess this up
I'm gonna tell you you were an idiot but
whatever you want to do honey and so you
know you just decide you go ahead
whatever you think's right no not
anymore not anymore I get on the same
page with my spouse and it changes
everything it's a really good question
and I did learn
the hard way because I bought a whole
bunch of real estate in my 20s my wife
never even saw it she never even saw the
deals whatever you want to do honey she
never even saw the deals and I don't do
deals like that anymore I don't do stuff
of size we don't make big decisions here
at the company without our spouses
involved my spouse involved if the
Ramsey family's involved the the in-laws
the married to my kids are involved you
know I just we involve theirs in the
multitude of counsel their safety and
proverbs 31 says who can find a virtuous
wife for her worth is far above rubies
the heart of her husband safely trusts
her and he will have no lack of gain
bone